okay
it's gamba time playing mr. nine Rana
let's play it's lady five what gambit to
play play Stafford I mean it could be
actually a bit difficult if White's
doesn't play what I want him to play
let's start with this Bishop c4
what can be can i play against Italian
I'll play okay I'll play nine six hoping
for Knight g5 then I'll play a track sir
yeah a Bishop c5 oops I hung in f7 pawn
please take it
I'll admit though that I haven't really
seriously studied the Traxler but I
would doubt my opponent is like so
booked up I don't even know if I've
played the Traxler like ever no people
have requested it there are two moves
here tonight takes f7 and Bishop takes
f7 and I don't even know what the
theoretical standing is Knight takes off
sevens refuted or link practically it's
very dangerous because the bishop takes
I assumed it takes f2 so I'm giving away
gave away this pawn probably the rook
and the bishop but the idea is out soon
I'll have Knight takes e4 and the Queen
will come in I mean I could play King f1
well I remember some line just vaguely
like King f1 and here here and then d5
takes Bishop g4 so I have to play Queen
e7 no other move really have to check
the theory after this game hello to
people get prophets brand you can a
radicand
chess we'd ok d5 is probably the move
I'm trying to figure out what to do
after a d5 takes Bishop g4 Bishop e2
seems pretty forcing I should be too
hmm
I'm sure this is like I mean mainline or
something
do I have some other options should eat
ooh who's my bishop still hanging and
that's not so comfortable I don't want
to trade like prematurely I could just
move my bishop back that doesn't seem
right maybe I can play d5 takes a 94
threatening Bishop g4 if King takes I
mean this looks kind of fun let's start
with d5 I'll decide
I mean I'm accelerating development
getting some initiative I'm going to
avoid looking in the chats just in case
people like some people might know that
mainline and I want to have unfair
assistance so I'll look at the chat
after the scheme mean white has options
if white takes with the bishop though I
trap the Queen which is nice I'm
expecting this if Bishop retreats I
probably just take on yes it depends
where the bishop retreats two moves here
I have Bishop g4 this should eat you I
take and also like I'll win the night at
some points probably so if I'll only be
down the exchange I'll have some attack
it should be fun
okay so this is I think critical moment
calculating a weird line Bishop g4
Bishop e2 94 takes takes takes then
Queen f6 or promise oh he doesn't have
Queen e6
my night controls e6 I'm giving up a lot
of material there but the king is almost
getting made in oh man
yeah I would be so much easier if I just
study this a little bit before flying it
Bishop g4 Bishop e2 94 so I'm sacking a
piece on g4 takes takes takes Queen f6
don't think there's any counter play I'm
controlling f3 so I'm guaranteed a
discover check the question is can white
defend I mean there's g3 mmm g3 could be
an issue
g3 Bishop takes g3 King g2 Queen here
King here hmm kind of run out of fuel in
that line so Bishop here here here takes
takes g3 mean
yeah the king has an escape route I
could try and win dock material but I
want an eight
so what about 94 immediately
maybe 94 immediately gives like more
options if I play Bishop g4 I just force
him into playing the best moves
really want to make this line work
though
I'm not seeing it
there's also a bishop here probably not
good it's my Knights attacks
okay let's play so hesitant Bishop g4
Bishop e2 ship g4 Bishop e2 what are my
options takes okay let's play Knight t4
it's so unusual my bishops still hanging
I'm assuming that this line should be
fine for me and Bishop g4 is now a
monster threat just a blue so I'm not
looking I'm trying to avoid the chat
because it's very possible people have
studied this variation but afterwards
all a look at the theory I'll learn
something h3 h3 looks very weakening it
stops us but it weakens g3 so I have 94
or 94
hmm it's also Quincy five possibilities
from with 94 I don't think I'm
threatening this cuz takes but me me I'm
threatening like Queen f6 so 94 here
Queen f6 the funny thing is I'm
struggling here but I might be like
three or four moves away from just
winning I think I'll play 94 Knights are
powerful it's crazy position I usually
avoid these positions this is not my
style of chess I like to be controlled
and positional and not wild like this
but okay I'm having some fun despite the
stress Queen f6 is of threats Queen f6
Knight g3 it's just meat and the key
lion I think d3 just Queen f6 takes
bishop g3 King g1 mates so I'm not sure
what White will do
you know the knight sir are doing some
work
there's queen h5 but that only like
gives me a target to attack as I call
house my g3 as a threat it's a sub
everyone rocks 23 it's a very nice name
thanks everyone rocks
yeah I think h3 may have been a key
mistake I was more scared of Knight c3
idea like Bishop e2 or 92 now I'm
feeling good
maybe I'll look at the chat now just add
blue what's up
tipsy ton says romantic chess yeah for
those who don't know romantic chess it's
kind of the style you sack everything
and then eventually you mates it's very
romantic
had some some games yesterday and arena
Kings
playing the same style played some
Halloween gambits and it's outside of my
comfort zone so this is uh yeah this is
a learning experience for me I haven't
scanned it I still have my list of
gambits
here's my my list I copied it to a
Google Doc Evans gambit should be here
somewhere
yeah there it is so I guess I'll add on
to the list I'll make note of which
gamuts I played which ones to knock off
the bucket list still need to play at
Banco gambit as well as the boat s
gambit and tamanna' yes
whoa I might be allergic to checkmating
because may this coming Queen f6
I don't think c3 accomplishes much I'm
happy to sack another piece
thanks for blessing me
yeah I think lights just dead lost now
the fall Kabir counter gambit I played a
couple days ago that was my first first
game in my gambit stream Queens gambit
declined boffin and considered a gambit
I guess but whose sacking upon ya Fox
acting a pawn I guess so
London is not a gambit but there might
be variations within the London where
you sack stuff yeah made as pretty and
unstoppable like white katralla T de
leus with Queen f3 or some random checks
but they don't really lead to much carp
offs Butler Eric if white plays 1 SF 3
can you play the over and or for gambit
blacks plays one g5 good luck and don't
complain about your position four leaf
clover faced with tears of joy
well thank you carpools Butler I think
you mean Knight f3
maybe SF 3 is a different language I
actually have that on my list I didn't
know that had a name but night of 3 g5
what is this called
the ohm uber Oberndorf er gambits ok g5
or g4
ok where is my mates I think it's made
in 2 or 3 Bishop III it's still great I
have 3 minor pieces in White's territory
unmoving about to be 4 pieces made
unstoppable
I mean after a game like this having not
really known anything in the Traxler I'm
inspired to play this in more games as I
feel like most players at least below
the rating of like 2000 probably won't
know that much and there's just so much
opportunity to win in like less than 15
moves by the Mexico southern Mexico
bring out there's a southern part in
Mexico
thanks much vitamin D for C alright GG
let's look at the theory real quick so
starting with Bishop c5 first of all
stockfish like the depth here I don't
think is like actually strong enough and
as far as I know Bishop takes f7 I think
is a better move but yeah this also the
evaluation doesn't reflect the nature of
the position so if I go to I mean this
has been playing the Masters play takes
takes King f1 yah27 d5 oh so I was
playing the most popular line I t4 so I
was scared of Knight c3 which has never
been played white usually plays d6 oh
wow and and doesn't lose and masteries
play
King takes off - wait what happens after
Knight c3 Bishop g4 Bishop e2 oh wow ooh
Queen I fates
sneaky very sneaky and whites kind of
just stuck that's very nice and then
okay after a king digs f2 I mean this is
crazy line Knight g4
Oh Knight g4 Queen c5 110 can you one
thank you Dirac Bisping or f1 Queen h4
okay that looks fun and then if g6
White's just winning well computers very
materialistic let's look on me chess
there should be more games both Queen
takes t69 of seven Queens to five it's
still very complicated like even okay
now computers shifting its evaluation
goes to show can't always trust initial
evaluation
some day I'll dig into this more deeply
but for now let's go back let's play
some more gambits so I played the track
sir um Jack sir I'm in the bold all the
gambit side play just to keep track
top hundred the tournament started about
half hour ago but I joined a little bit
late let's play d4 I played before my
last stream a lot I'll play a Queen's
Gambit the most safe and solid and
reputable gambits that there is we have
a Queens gambit declined that's fine
with me
oh maybe I can play on Marshall gambit
yeah we're gonna have a gamma turning
into another gambits bishop before
coming so I'm gambling a pawn and I'm
gonna forget exactly what to do
do I take on or do I play Knight each I
know both both moves are playable
probably doesn't matter what I play
I mean Bishop e2 looks logical 92 I mean
I'll stack another pawn following the
spirit of playing gambits I know there's
some crazy move like Knight a six and
then Bishop f8 at some points Queen digs
g2 Wow
I don't think this is actually
considered good if I remember correctly
remember studying this from Locke's
perspective also Queen d6 is maybe
coming alive like we knew six now wait
Queen d6 how does a black defend and
threatening this oh that's nice Queen d6
here here here I Castle queenside or
just rook d1 King c7 Queen d8 mates
I guess guess there's 97 97 defense
so the question is do I play Queen d6
first or Bishop a3 first probably Bishop
f3 just to see where the Queen goes
Queen g5
hmm okay so I'm down DuPont's but I have
lots of development I have the darks for
Bishop White's dark squares or wheat or
blacks dark squares are weak then go
play 92 here looks very natural
preparing rook g1 hitting the Queen with
tempo protecting my king imagining some
line like night a six rook g1 queen e5
Bishop f8 King takes a faith and Queen
d8 mates otherwise G Saturn's a target
it's interesting position good evening -
Thomas Mason was our Dean I don't think
I said hello to too many people I
started the stream and then just got
wrapped up in the games
yeah pawn ins was moving very quickly in
the opening but now slowing down not so
easy to like fully develop as bishops
kind of sad
hello to chalky 89 and soaking wet site
welcome back
I'm not taking challenges at least right
now because I'm playing the daily rapid
arena I'll share the link in the chat
though I might be back later tonight to
do some some viewer challenges it's not
a bad idea okay
97 makes sense so rook g1 looks enticing
Queen d6 also looks enticing
thinking Ricci one Queen a five and the
queen is just gonna be a target Queen f6
okay can i play this and just win the
rook and give away the bishop I mean
that's probably best but there might be
counter play ooh oh this is tricky
bishop see three ticks ticks some
Knights e5 move
but no this this can't work my c5 I take
93
kingi - I'm threatening this let's play
the ship here oh there's a 5v5 defense
forgot about you five
be5 my Chi 3 looks fun let's do it
bits from Kenny come laughs oh boy 100
bonus 10 play the boat as gambit or
that's Casey Kenny Lau boat as gambit
will come unintentionally winning we
least expected and against someone much
liberated and my opponents
but okay I've played to canvas this game
I've played the Queen's Gambit and the
Marshall gambits Halloween gamut I
played I played twice yesterday and
arena Kings scored two out of two
against reasonably high rated players so
yeah after a five which i think is
expected
I mean 95 maybe is also a move any five
looks awkward though for luck Wow so
that's going for this line happening
back some material ah so this night will
come in so f2 after you can be defended
with this move also I have like
attacking ideas rookie eights if they
might come before
yeah this is looking very nice
you have to explain what the fried
spaghetti gambit is there might be a
fried liver and there's a fried liver
variation but fried spaghetti sounds
questionable
I do have my my gambit list
ooh okay so the nights are kind of
coming into play I just take oh there's
such a nice line look at this line takes
if Queen takes its mate in to rook g8
skini seven Queen d8 mates so takes 93
expected that I just take I soccer queen
it's a boat as gambit and then I win the
Queen back with a rook moving all the
way around the board it's like a normal
rook lift and then a reverse rook lift
let's do this okay boat is gambits
coming in five four three two bad timing
it'll come eventually unless Queen takes
f6 is played then I just meet so
disappointed just to show what could
have happened I'm not so disappointed I
was it overall a nice game analysis for
I was expecting 93 93 takes takes and
then my rook wins the Queen here here
here here okay
yeah overall I'm just curious what's
more popular Bishop e2
I think Queen takes g2 is questionable
yeah 96 is a Manman 96 is a bishop f8
Bishop F eights playable may be the
other line 92 96 bishop f8 some main
move here yeah it's very unusual if
you've never seen this before about like
g7 is weak and like he can't take that
bishop because mates and with Queen g6
then the Queen can comment in crazy
position rook t1 that's a fun gambit I
didn't even have that on my list or did
I oh I did the marshal gambits marshal
gambits for black marshal ganda for
whites so I've played I played this and
I play Queen's Gambit all right let's
move on back to tournaments some fun
games so far no game lasting more than
20 moves black in this game do you have
a favorite gambit probably the staffer
yemen's d4 Oh
people were suggesting a bank oh I'll
try and play a bingo bango is not really
something I've studied so much I have
had a few students who played it okay
this might be hard to actually achieve a
bank oh and can I play a banco against
this or I just have to wait until white
plays d5 okay I'll wait until white
plays d5
I'm also gamma ting this pawn if I wants
to take it I'm kind of disappointed that
light isn't doing what I want white to
do
yeah the Banco gambit is not related to
a bento box and the two are are slightly
different
okay I'm really trying to induce t5 or
induce this Haidee 5 so I think the
night should be should go back or should
go to a 5 maybe just go back I lose I'll
lose a tempo but I induced d5 and I can
really develop some day 2 to d7
[Music]
so this is some weird Benoni of some
sorts like a Benoni but I lost a couple
Tempe ok b5 time until late [ __ ] Oh
I mean I'm sure there's gambits emerging
from every opening are you just like at
any point you can sack material fur for
compensation and the Dragons
specifically can't think of any there's
some line wear black socks exchange on
f8 Oh fried spaghetti is a made-up
gambit is England gambit on the list
England gambit is on the list it's right
here 'if I've not accepting the free
pawn alright this looks ugly but I'll
try and make it work I only have one
piece beyond the eighth-ranked but it's
not that bad I don't have or do I have
weaknesses I might be losing a pawn but
that's part of the opening plan if take
smite Knight comes to life if a six and
maybe I just went up on so Knight takes
b5 hmm so we could just be trading here
I could take here d6 I just take
okay so I don't think I'll be losing any
material Bishop h8 fissure random except
it's not true fissure random because the
King has to be between the rooks for
Kassim to work
yeah this uh this cluster of pawns could
be strong later
ie4 v h6 g5 so d6 I had considered I
didn't think it was an issue though
because I can take how White's cabining
trying to give me a taste of my own
medicine
so if I take there's this pin well maybe
why it just takes takes takes takes and
then Bishop e7 in the end if that
happens I might play E for just try and
make things complicated
if it takes Queen D 5 a move to try and
trap the rook but I have Bishop e7 also
have a six here now let's say with notes
should be okay
I feel like people are now just making
up candidates in the chat the fruit
snack gambits never heard of or is that
when you give someone fruit snacks you
make their day snacks for nice I don't
have any with me right now only of tf6
ban yeah
f6 was a backup option but f6 is very
detrimental to the bishop and I think e
for is gonna be a very powerful idea
even more powerful than f6 yeah so this
was expected and now now my my intention
that wants to play e4 can calculate ie
four takes if I take this way I lose
exchange but after E 4 takes I would
like to take on b2
the rookies hit it Frick b1 I play
Bishop c3 let's do it and thanks for the
sub tuner with a or tuner tuner with a
two-month streak appreciate that now
taking on g2 doesn't really fix things I
don't think
but after after it takes takes what's
going on I think it's actually winning
material for me unless I'm mistaken it
takes
I'm temporarily down a rook but two
pieces are hanging or no three three
things are hanging and I just want to
pawn it forked be one then I play this
oh but then there's my tea too but
that's okay
I'll win at least one minor piece back I
might be down exchange but down the
exchange for two ponts so it's an
interesting imbalance
if the rope moves somewhere else I take
I can't take on a three because my rock
hangs on on AIDS so almost certainly
I'll take the bishop next
yeah there's also the possibility I
could just give away this rook like
there's maybe castling
but that doesn't appear to be great
maybe it's just training there's also
this move and then I take the rook and
light still attacked it's complicated I
like the fact my opponents thinking
every game so far has been crazy I think
some very extreme imbalances from very
early on
Karam are welcome back I will be right
back I need a tissue but first let's
take the rook
King d2
I can't really take because on my rook
gets trapped hmm play this move
good let's move Bishop c4 I hit f2 and
Knight takes d4 pawn takes d4 I just
have immaculate pawns in the center it
feels weird so they willingly give away
the bishop hair but I defend c5 more
bets
subway 100 bonus 10 play the Omega Isis
game but Eric one d4 at 5 2 and a 385
impressive how it says notation so
that's f5 if I understand that that
seems very dubious so that's the gambit
for black seems very dubious I'll keep
that in mind though umm let's develop a
knight
yeah the pawns are I mean I might have
just a nice pawn chain I'll win connect
5 it's hard for a white to attack
anything like this pawns not defended
but it's hard to attack ok f3 that's
attacking it
ok Blade III King g3 and then that's a
mate's Bishop f5 mate actually this is
looking very nice he has to move back
and then I play this hit the rook rook
moves somewhere d3 let's do it oh wait
let's start with this almost played
Bishop f5 first please play King d3 Wow
look at that look at that mate that's
such a nice mate just minor pieces and
pawns doing work doing work well the
King 22 moves still a miniature all
their mates
that's very thumbnail worthy people on
YouTube watching in the future hope you
enjoyed that neither comments smash the
like button back to tournament I don't
even know what that was I was like a
attempted Banco gambit benoni sort of
structure ok and thank you ex red X Reds
tag
I assume that stands for Germany thanks
for subbing 34th place I'm not intending
to try and win the tournaments I do have
to go before the term intends but I'll
try and getting a couple more games so
here's my master list I guess I can
highlight Banco it was an attempted
Banco still have a lot more to to
attempt if I might next game I'll play e
4 let's play E 4 where do i play d4
let's play e4 see what he does what's a
Duras gambit I feel like I've heard of
that before also what's the gamut in its
appearance oh I have a I have an idea
there's a line where I play g4 let's
start with Knight f3 mantle King thanks
for subbing wait a minute I need to play
gambit
it's like b4 b4 what does it be for
I don't know any gamuts against a
specific sort of setup I'm trying to
create something like D for D for his
most natural let's play d4 maybe
preparing before yeah II five I'll have
an idea
but my idea doesn't work I just want to
play gambit
maybe some some ideas still with g4
perhaps maybe I'll start with Bishop e2
this is gonna be a slightly delayed
gambit also yeah what is the Duras
gambit Oh II for f5 maybe later against
a low-rated opponent I played the whole
or the the Colorado gambit
the other day II for knight c6 Knight f3
f5 there's before work now oh that would
lose lose a d4 pawn
I mean I'm playing a good player so I
don't want to like sack anything that's
just completely terrible play Bishop III
when the time is right I'll sack
something I'm still looking to play b4
before or takes I have some file to work
with
and I like the movie searching for bobby
fisher' I've probably seen that movie
like 15 to 20 times it was good movie
all right before time
it's interesting idea no black takes I
got a media initiative probably went
back the pond
sack the king king d2 is very deep
ooh stick with a pawn I want to open up
my flank files and probably just leave
the king in the center you can still
take the pawn doesn't on it
ooh okay let's put the rook here c5 what
is c5
I mean I'm tempted now just to sack like
Queenie three giveaway the pawn 85 not
sure if that works
hmm it's also queen g2
maybe Queen d2 looks very questionable
though I could I just take and trade
some n game hmm I do want to attack
I have some idea I'm gonna start with
Queen d2 I'm not gonna play 95 because
this trade is just good for black so
after it takes I'm gonna play Knight d12
III to f5 to g7 someday okay so I looked
at this I assumed me five Knight has to
move and now the bishop can come to life
like Bishop coming to d3
there's targets against the King side if
mighty Saturn that could maybe take the
pawn alright so I'm down the pawn I have
some attack not sure class considering
probably just the three Knight moves
I for looks natural taking the pawn
looks very playable let's take the pawn
and soon my pieces will come to life
black might try and trade Queens like
move the night somewhere
oh there's interesting move for black
does that work
black has a I think black could have
maybe taken here idea Bishop f6 but okay
black like Queen c7
Queen c7 attacks two pawns c2 in in e5 I
care less about C - so I'm thinking f4
here
yeah I really don't care about c2 Queen
take C - I can play Bishop d3 or maybe I
can just take the night Queen g2 is a
move
Bishop d3 also a move there's so many
moves I don't think this doesn't move
because Queen c3
hmm
yeah blacks can encounter play I'm
getting low on time I might just play
Quincy for just simplify a little bit
let's do it
it's equal material but still I've been
imbalanced just in terms of position and
even if we trade Queens I'll still have
potential to attack I have the bishop to
the rook
Wow Queen a5 King f1 is probably a safe
move
just getting out of danger
I'm probably happy that block didn't
rate Queens because now there's still a
lot more attacking potential I just need
two moves which block is not giving me
let's play Queenie for Queen d5 probably
coming
Queen d5 I have this move
Nichola welcome back you're joining at a
intense moment I'm long time playing a
good player I've been playing some
slightly dubious chess this game but
it's kind of working off but for the
next pretty much for the rest of the
game I have to stay more focused and not
look too much at the chat I'm in 36
place in the tournament
Queen c5
okay so 93 oh there's a nice line let's
play 93 if what does it work I think it
works if worked d4 I take on g7 King
takes g7 Queen 64 takes and then this
the same thing with Queen d4 I just take
on g7
between c3 attacking the rook maybe rook
e1
I want to play rook g3 soon maybe even
lift over ooh okay I think this works I
think it just winds up on but it's a
valuable pawn this is nice oh I can play
that at five immediately yeah why not
I'll see where the king goes
maybe I'll take with nights to prepare
Bishop d3 oh and then there's Queen h3
check wait I have to be careful am I
losing no I'm not losing I have this
move Queen each tree kind of comes out
of nowhere but thankfully I'm not
getting made and I don't think man it's
closer have to be very careful sometimes
this happens you get so excited about
some tactic
you forgot about opponents like follow
ups thankfully my queen controls g2
which could have been blacks meaning
square
but okay my threats Bishop d3 not too
much for about to do
getting better on time
there's this move Knight c4 I'm trying
to access d2 but the very least I can
just take it
remove Bishop d3 would be a very
dangerous free move I think we need
three is expected but so we'll see what
that does
rook g8 rook g8 then Bishop d3
yeah we're both trying to attack on the
same side
but really black only has a queen and
rook to attack with I have all my pieces
to defend with
probably just want to play rook g1 next
interesting move perché one
yeah at this point it's just a matter of
simplifying has my rainin gone down 100
points or so um yes in rapid chess if I
lose so like a low-rated player it goes
down a lot I'd like a few bad losses
maybe like a month or two ago so not
super recently Apple chess requesting a
four-night c64 f5 is that playable maybe
that's also playable that's is that also
the Colorado gambit but yeah I'm not
super attached to my my rapid raining
it's just a number that reflects how
good I am though it's more about the
quality of the games and anything else
so I think the ponent will flag I mean
okay the game is either gonna add into
PI flagging resignation or techniques
hopefully I'm not the one getting maiden
who played Bishop XIII now Bishop d3
wait Queen takes takes Queen G for okay
let's go for it
hmm let's go for this and then Knight f5
a threatening force mates or maybe not
force me you see as Bishop f8 Oh a
threatening to chase the King to Yates
oh now it's force mate if the bishop
locked on I feel I have Bishop b5 Queen
takes and I hear forking in the end but
also black is flagging okay yeah just to
show like the final tactical possibility
a fact is nothing and this is a nice
line Bishop b5 takes your bishops pins
okay interesting game yeah I kind of had
to create a gambit there with b4 and in
Queen d2 I think was interesting to just
yeah just give away the the pawn it's
weird because I move backwards twice but
it was always like reasonable intention
all about getting my Knight f5 or just
III rook takes g7 was nice okay
one more game 23rd place
how long did it take you to reach 2,000
reading I started playing chess my first
tournament was when I was 8 years old I
had 2000 when I was I think 13 years old
12 or 13 okay let's play e4 again c5 do
I play in Mora what else can i play
yeah butts against Sicilian complaint
wing gambit let's play let's play a
moral have some fun inspired by us
Raymond oh this is ok this is a line I
play as black so now I have to remember
my crap I know why castles here casting
I have six I think might be five in this
position have to remember my gaming is a
sermon because a sermon was like so
booked up
I think it's e5 here white sacks another
pawn Knight g4 Knight g4 I think is the
best move and then is it it's 96 here
have to remember there's also a Bishop
f4 maybe Bishop f4 now house B Bishop f4
Bishop a4 a6 and then we trade yeah
Bishop f4 I remember some line and this
is a one line actually no kind of deeply
just have to remember it's like I've
studied this very extensively from black
ninety six looks nasty but when I wind
up with a pawn on d6 it's kind of just
stuck and it still takes effort to break
through but as far as I know this is
supposed to be good for whites
especially this move but why I don't
think I messed up did I mess up
Knight takes e5
hmm
was I supposed to play 96 maybe I was
but know this I mean this looks so nice
for whites takes takes Queen D for d6
maybe just like rook d1
should just start with this oh there's
also a rookie one immediately
also queen h5 possibilities
there's a decent amount to consider here
so take sticks Queen H 5d6 was forced I
can even take like rooks you mana
Bishop's push up somewhere Bishop e7 and
then like taking here or even might see
satin takes here okay let's start by
taking this is pretty force like queen
h5 and Queen e2 also possible but that
allows f6 so Queen HIV prevents f6
forces d69 3 I just take it so the line
is takes takes and then rook C one
threatening Knight c7 and Bishop b5 I'm
not sure how lock defends maybe Bishop
d6 Bishop d6 I take Queen takes rook d1
it looks nice I have all my pieces box
not developed the Queen's the target
let's go for this spend a lot of time
there trying to figure out this line
hopefully it's worth it everywhere
heroes are abundant okay so takes
well--there's Bishop c5 Bishop c5 I mean
maybe just b4
there's also a bishop t7 this is still
tricky
I could play rook c1 first actually keep
some tension still threatening Knight c7
then there's 96 okay let's take trust my
first instinct
I'm down two pawns but okay all my
pieces will be active all the VAX pieces
still on the back rank and I have a
threats again it looks like some weird
actually it not so much like Fischer
random only the queen is Miss place
I'm realizing there's some idea Bishop
here I maybe I could still play this
takes and then this cuz I'm threatening
f7 so Bishop d7 here here here Queen d6
takes King d8 rook d1 should be likes
hot
Queenie Savin my take on d7 so g 6g 6 is
a move
so there's moves to consider here
there's Queen f3 here and maybe even
going for dark squares these moves
probably just Bishop e7 so Queen f3 in
corn a3 has idea of Queen f6
trying to calculate Bishop h6 Knight c7
King f8 and I take it should be good
and yeah the threaded Queen a six this
has to be winning somehow for awaits
have to dedicate this game to Marquess
Herman well mark a sermon in the chats
or gasser was like I will I wasn't
looking the chat and then I realized
it's why so serious let me give a shout
out are there there's seven lives right
I'll just copy paste a sermon says this
looks looks familiar must be Siberian
not sure what that means not familiar
with names but this came from this came
from the line that I played against mark
after my g4 I forgot whether to play 96
first or Bishop f4 first I think that's
Bishop f4 because I remember some line
where Asics here takes takes b5
premature Bishop t5 wait Bishop e6 wins
oh it's my move
okay Bishop d6 have to go back and see
what the professional preparation is
rook d1 just looks crushing Bishop e6
didn't even consider Bishop e6
oh that's so nasty but how does that
work pawn takes I'll probably just rook
c1 if Bishop e6 works that's so great
but I'm happy with the slime too
Marcus Welby thanks for subbing man
there's so much pressure playing the
Smith Morra with a sermon watching to
live up to his greatness okay I think
black is is just losing here the bishop
moves to some safe square then they see
seven happens otherwise I just win the
bishop
yeah this is an attempt
still actually takes some work
do I take on e6 I take c6 or do I just
take the rook
play Bishop takes e6 as well
calculating Bishop takes c6 takes takes
King g8 rook d7
bishops pin to that fun
so Queenie ain't that I take bishops
Hill again let's do that I might even
have a situation where I have a queen
and two rooks actually that might be the
final move rook c7
I'll have the triple patty on the
seventh ring I think
Keeney it could be a move but then I go
back at the very least
so King g8 rook d7 Queenie it only moves
to the Femina Bishan
I guess there's politics pawn take
sticks it can't be good for black that's
gonna be seven heaven looking at takes
takes Queen uh fades but then still
takes followed by Brooke c7 so Queenie
eight now takes rook b8 I take on e7 if
the bishop moves anywhere then this how
does that work though takes
maybe I should save the night first
yeah I was just imagining that this is
devastating but after upon takes I guess
I I thought rook g7 our g7 takes takes
that's I don't think it's winning it's
probably losing I mean this is still
probably working somehow maybe Queen f6
that's scary I don't like giving away
material
I think I'll just save the night where
doesn't I move
probably here
yeah tonight will be valuable
a 94 now
okay now threatening the triple battery
night is safe applying pressure should
be reasonable my c7 would have lost the
rook and then allowed the pin
so if I just take
I'm [ __ ] is putting up resistance roti
it's a good move
gotta watch for time too
just went upon I guess this is not the
finish I was imagining to this game I
thought there is gonna be some rural
checkmates but now it's just an N game
I'm up upon there's some calm for black
maybe King g7 Queen Queen III hmm wow
what does this move let's play rook f1
some g4 ideas
and we're gonna have some endgame
cooking for versus working for but I
have my rook behind the past pawn and
this is very important and now my king
should come in first to be four let's
play g3 safety measures
Howie four and then I'll walk the canyon
fifteen seconds what a finish
five lachman's Connect four let's take a
box making up a spawn way this is still
complicated
oh dear okay I have to try and survive
this
oh man that's what the game came down to
look at that move what was that move
rook t2 still theory I feel dirty to
wash my hands take a bath yeah I wonder
if I missed some easy
I think someone had mentioned I miss
this rook takes f7 does this work
this probably works takes and then this
now this looks crushing its tactics 94
missed opportunity but a sermon hey
Nicola
only I sacked a queen we did trade
Queen's a sermon was saying Bishop takes
you six it's so nice wow what a move
cliff takes on this and if takes I
assume Roxy one just didn't come to mind
this is still very nice lesson 9 I rook
cc7
yeah no reason to take the b-pawn yeah
and then okay light was still better but
it wasn't easy I got so long time well I
think that was a fun way to end things
um yeah some very interesting games this
stream this will probably on YouTube
shoutouts to future YouTube viewers
leave a comment leave your questions
leave your suggestions below for the
twitch audience I also have to take off
maybe I'll be back later
stay tuned be sure to hit the follow
button you get notified when I go live
uh and yeah thanks everyone nilesy
saying Grob someday but the Grob is in
the gamut but maybe I'll have a grab
stream at some point okay what to do
let us well the Sun to raid to the
one-and-only is actually a gambit named
after this person I'm about to raid
Alexandre botas she is streaming blitz
and analysis okay thanks again everyone
appreciate the viewership I'll see you
guys in the future goodbye